[Musica]
tutti conosciamo la storia dei tre
porcellini timmy tommy e jimmy sono tre
fratelli che decidono di abbandonare la
casa della propria madre per andare a
vivere da soli i tre fratellini escono e
si avventurano nel parco per andare a
costruire autonomamente la loro casa il
primo costruisce molto rapidamente una
casa con quello che trova nel bosco la
paglia il secondo decide di costruire la
casa in una mattinata vicino l'albero e
prende la legna proprio da questo il
terzo molto più attento e meticoloso
costruisce la propria casa in mattoni in
un'intera giornata e utilizzando anche
il cemento tutti sappiamo come va a
finire la storia il lupo butta giù in un
soffio la casa in paglia butta giù in un
soffio la casa in legno ma non riesce a
distruggere la casa di mattoni che
diventa l'unico punto di salvezza per i
tre fratellini e lo fa prendendo ad
esempio la casa la casa che diventa un
guscio una protezione per i tre
fratellini
ma la casa è un guscio anche per noi è
una protezione dall esterno dalle
temperature fredde della temperature
calde e per questo rappresenta anche un
elemento che eric ed energia
oggi parliamo di sostenibilità la casa è
un elemento fondamentale basti pensare
che il 40 per cento dei consumi
energetici mondiali è attribuito
all'edilizia in particolare a quella
residenziale
quindi è importante valutare come come
si possono contenere i consumi
energetici nelle abitazioni durante il
mio percorso di studio affrontato la
progettazione in maniera tradizionale un
po come il terzo porcellino ma sono
sempre stato affascinato dalla mentalità
del primo e del secondo porcellino
infatti fin dal primo approccio che ha
avuto quella ricerca durante le mie tesi
di laurea ho progettato dei moduli
abitativi in legno
un po come ha fatto il secondo
porcellino nel costruire la prima casa
ma ero affascinato ancora dall'idea di
poter prender
era il mio territorio il materiale per
costruire la mia casa come fece il primo
porcellino pensando al mio territorio
penso all'agricoltura al cuore pulsante
della mia terra
però l'idea è di dell'agricoltura e
dell'edilizia insieme non sposavano
nella mia testa
devo dire che è l'approccio che è
possibile seguire infatti nella
progettazione può essere di due tipi si
può categorizzare nell'approccio hi tech
l'approccio tecnologico in cui si
utilizzano controlli sistemi di
controllo e gestione dell'energia che
possono migliorare l'efficienza
energetica o ancora utilizzare materiali
altamente tecnologici che migliorano la
performance di un edificio ma è
possibile anche avere un altro approccio
quello che io preferisco talvolta
l'approccio low tech
l'approccio che utilizza materiali
poveri ma con un approccio innovativo e
in quel caso anche si può migliorare la
sostenibilità e il miglioramento anche
energetico di un edificio durante la mia
ricerca ho studiato e analizzato anche
quello che viene fatto nel mondo e con
mio grande stupore ho visto che in ogni
parte del mondo dove vi è uno sviluppo
agricolo quindi ovunque c'è una
produzione è una è un sottoprodotto di è
un giovane un ricercatore uno studente
che prova a ipotizzarne l'applicazione
degli scarti per materiali in edilizia e
quindi questo mi ha fatto pensare come
anche io potessi fare la stessa cosa a
partire dal mio territorio pensando al
mio territorio viene subito in mente
pensare alle distese di agrumi la
sicilia conta il 90 per cento della
produzione di agrumi in italia l'italia
è al secondo posto in europa per la
produzione di agrumi e quindi è
possibile pensare l'utilizzo di questo
materiale
poiché proprio la produzione rappresenta
un elemento fondamentale per il nostro
territorio
ma cosa ancor più importante è che nel
nostro territorio è anche presente la
trasformazione e il 90 per cento delle
industrie che trasformano gli agrumi
il 90 per cento del peso di un agrume
rappresenta uno scarto quindi quando io
spremo un'arancia il 90 per cento è
commestibile il 50 per cento è
commestibile il 50 per cento è un
sottoprodotto composto da buccia
restituì di polpa e semi ho avuto la
fortuna di trascorrere un periodo di
ricerca all'estero nella nazione in cui
si produce al primo posto producono
agrumi la spagna e li ancor di più ho
visto che nella città di madrid come
fosse diffusa la produzione di
sottoprodotti in ogni supermercato è
presente infatti una macchina come
questa
una macchina che produce scarti in
realtà produce succo
ma il 50 per cento di questo di questo
evento è uno scarto
ho avuto la fortuna di incontrare di
trovare la stessa macchinetta anche
nella caffetteria della ii università e
quindi mi sono subito premurato di
chiedere al responsabile del bar di
fornirmi ogni giorno quello che
produceva questa macchinetta ma non il
succo lo scarto per lui era un favore
che stavo facendo
poiché stavo togliendo uno scatolo di
bucce di arance che ogni sera avrebbe
dovuto portare in spazzatura
solo dopo un mese mi chiese ma ogni
giorno cosa fai con queste scatole di
arance e io risposi che magari un giorno
avrebbe potuto trovare un materiale
prodotto proprio con quelle bucce anche
a casa sua
inizialmente era un po scettico in
questa risposta però devo dire che poi
ho visto l'entusiasmo e la felicità di
contribuire a un progetto come questo un
progetto a cui però io ancora non
credevo perché non credevo fosse
possibile ottenere un materiale da
questi da questi scarti infatti le
difficoltà il percorso è stato lungo per
trovare un processo che effettivamente
potesse essiccare ma al contempo
pressare e compattare il materiale per
rimuovere il contenuto d'acqua ma al
contempo per avere un pannello
utilizzabile nel mio settore
nell'edilizia avere una scoperta del
genere per me è stato veramente
entusiasmante vedere che effettivamente
da una da una pressa e una contemporanea
essiccatura di questo materiale ne possa
uscire un un prodotto auto legato auto
incollato ma è stato ancor più
interessante valutare le proprietà
termiche le proprietà meccaniche
proprietà acustiche di questo materiale
e confrontarle e vedere come ci siano
analogie e talvolta anche miglioramenti
rispetto quelle trovate da altri miei
colleghi in altre parti del mondo
ma cosa ancor più interessante è stato
vedere come ci siano delle somiglianze
sia possibile confrontare le proprietà
di questi materiali con i materiali
attualmente in commercio quindi
materiali che attualmente utilizziamo un
edilizia
sì perché io immagino questo materiale
esattamente nella stessa funzione che
esso assolve durante la sua vita e
durante la crescita del frutto perché è
una protezione un guscio che protegge la
rancia durante la crescita e la
maturazione con la sua struttura porosa
riesce infatti a inglobare l'aria ea
mantenere un buon isolamento termico al
suo interno e quindi consente potrebbe
consentire un efficientamento energetico
delle nostre case ma io immagino questo
materiale anche nel settore
dell'arredamento nel settore del design
perché è un materiale che sentiamo
nostro è un materiale che viene dalla
nostra terra e quindi tutti vorremmo
avere nelle nostre case
infatti io reputo che è un materiale
possa essere sostenibile un materiale
come questo poiché è un materiale che
deriva dalla un processo produttivo
industriale di trasformazione di un
agrume che è al termine avrebbe un uno
scarto uno scarto che provocherebbe un
costo un costo economico legato al
trasporto è legato alla dismissione ma
anche un costo ambientale per il
territorio che dovrebbe andare ad
assorbire pensare di reinserirlo in un
nuovo processo produttivo come quello
della realizzazione di un materiale
consentirebbe di aumentarne il valore
economico commerciale e aumentare al
contempo la sostenibilità delle nostre
abitazioni degli oggetti che la
compongono
tornando alla al pensiero dei tre
porcellini
io in fondo ho pensato e ho agito come
il primo porcello
però l'ho fatto con la metodologia del
terzo porcellino con i giusti tempi e
con il giusto approccio
quindi quello che potremmo fare tutti
noi è ragionare come un ipotetico quarto
porcellino che pensa di costruire la
propria casa in una maniera differente
se come seguendo i principi più recenti
della progettazione magari costruendo
una casa solida con una struttura in
legno ma ben coibentata con materiali
naturali provenienti magari da prodotti
di riciclo e nonostante io fino ad oggi
pensavo fosse impossibile utilizzare
prodotti di scarto agricolo
oggi posso dire che questo è possibile
[Applauso]
[Musica]